alors donc à moins d'un an de l'élection
présidentielle le candidat insoumis
s'est-il tirer une balle dans le pied at
il porté un coup d'arrêt à sa dynamique
de campagne c'est le décryptage et nous
inviter j casanova consultant en
stratégie en communication passés par
plusieurs ministères et françois cocq
essayiste et ancien orateurs nationale
de la france
insoumise bonsoir messieurs avant de
vous donner la parole voyez les
réactions de christian estrosi le maire
excellèrent de nice et de la licra la
ligue internationale contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme
cette manière d'expliquer le passé et de
prédire l'avenir à un nom le complotisme
c'est un fonds de commerce détestable
qui repose sur un mode de pensée
simpliste et opportuniste que tout
citoyen responsable doit dénoncer
après s'être attaqué à nos forces de
l'ordre jean luc mélenchon dérive vers
les pires théories complotistes par ces
propos il vient salir la mémoire des
français victimes de la barbarie
islamiste
c'est indigne honteux minable
messieurs jean luc mélenchon at il été
complotistes gilles casanova écoutez il
y a deux lectures qu'on peut faire ligne
du point de vue de la communication
l'autre du point de vue de la stratégie
si j'étais un communicant cynique je
remarquerai la chose suivante
lorsqu'on demande aux gens tous les ans
et la croix qui fait ce sondage est ce
que ça s'est passé comme la télé la
radio ou les journaux le dise il y à
entre 3 et 5 % des gens qui disent oui
ça s'est exactement passé comme la télé
la radio ou les journaux le disent c'est
à dire qu'il ya 95% des gens qui disent
quelque chose d'un peu différent si on
regarde les études qui sont faites sur
l'idée que c'est un complot qui mène le
monde et que tout ce que nous voyons est
organisé par un petit groupe de gens qui
complètent is qui contrôle un peu tout
ça est que la vérité est ailleurs
il y à entre 20 et 25 % de gens qui
pensent cela
donc si vous êtes candidat si vous
n'avez pas l'ambition de gagner
si vous êtes prêt à vous mettre à dos
tous qu'il ya un an
de formation supérieure et tout ce qui
est présent dans le système médiatique
le système politique de système
institutionnel et que vous voulez
absorber ces 20 à 25%
vous faites comme ça ne s'est pas du
tout un dérapage c'est une construction
vous avez entendu le propos le petit
bonhomme qui sort du chapeau ce n'est
pas le pen ses écrits et s'est dit très
précisément c'est emmanuel macron et
c'est dans d'autres pays celui qui est
élu un comédien en amérique latine celui
qui jouait le rôle du président dans une
série de télévision ukrainienne
il est très précis dans son propos on
n'est pas du tout dans ce que les taux
de chô fatigué appelle un dérapage
on est dans une de construction très
précises d'un propos qui va toucher 20 à
25 % des gens pour leur dire voilà c'est
comme ça que ça se passe
alors on peut penser c'est l'aspect
stratégique que cela lui interdit tout à
fait l'ambition d'être président
l'ambition de rassembler autour de lui
des gens dans l'élite du pays même une
minorité car là il vient de se mettre à
dos à peu près tout ce qui existe en
dehors des responsables de la france
insoumise dans ceux qui sont en mesure
de s'exprimer dans le système médiatique
et même au delà
donc il fait le pari d'être dans
l'opposition mais de peser plus que les
autres dans l'opposition il fait le pari
qu'on finira par oublier ses formules un
peu sévère d'ailleurs vous avez vu
autour de lui par exemple clémentine
autain réécrit tout ça elle dit que
c'est l'extrême droite dont il parle
bon c'est pas l'extrême droite qui a
sorti emmanuel macron du chapeau
c'est pas ça qui l'a dit mais donc vous
voyez qu'il y a une stratégie perdante
mais avec aussi éventuellement le coût
d'un joueur un vrai joueur avec la
martingale
si cette stratégie perdante lui donnais
20 points et que eux ils soient devant
le troisième c'est lui qui serait face à
marine le pen est donc cette martingale
marcherait en sa faveur
françois cocq votre analyse at il tenu
des propos complotistes jean luc
mélenchon je suis assez d'accord avec
l'analyse que vient de produire monsieur
monsieur casanova à savoir que la
dimension stratégique pèse beaucoup
là-dedans mais elle révèle surtout
beaucoup de choses c'est à dire que si
les de tels propos peuvent être tenus en
tout cas si jean luc mélenchon a essayé
d'en pointer ce qu'ils pensaient être
une ligne de crête est bien c'est que il
cherche à capter des segments électoraux
il n'a plus vocation à s'adresser au
grand nombre ce ne sont pas des propos
qui peuvent être des propos rassembleurs
qui vise à construire une perspective
majoritaire à construire une majorité
populaire
aujourd'hui il est dans autre chose à
reprendre des petits bouts d'électorat
en faisant des coûts électoraliste des
coups tactiques des coûts de
communication et peut-être que cette
démarche effectivement s'inscrit là de
l'an mais j'y vois toutefois une limite
n'oublions pas que nous sommes dans un
calendrier électoral beaucoup beaucoup
plus rapproché encore que l'élection
présidentielle et ce faisant
jean luc mélenchon va à l'encontre des
intérêts de celles et ceux qui au sein
de la france et insoumise vont aller se
présenter devant les électeurs dans
quelques jours seulement aux élections
départementales aux élections régionales
qui peut croire une telle polémique sera
sans incidence sur les scores de ces
candidats qui pour beaucoup d'entre eux
sont dans des situations qui sont pas à
des plus les plus à même de leur
permettre d'être d'être au second tour
donc c'est une c'est une stratégie bien
dangereuses y compris contre son propre
camp
mais on peut avoir aussi une autre
lecture et je l'assumé à monsieur
casanova c'est que il ya quand même
peut-être une part de dérapage
je sais que vous venez de dire que vous
n'aimez pas le terme mais en partie
incontrôlée c'est à dire d'une absence
de maîtrise là dedans si vous avez
écouté l'émission en entier de jean luc
mélenchon il est dit des choses
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude d'entendre dans
sa bouche des erreurs historiques
importantes
il a par exemple dans la même émission
dit que traiter monsieur daladier de
collabo dit qu'il avait terminé pendu
après la seconde guerre mondiale donc
non seulement ce sont des propos qui
sont totalement faux historiquement mais
intel contre sens dans la bouche de
quelqu'un comme jean luc mélenchon
interpelle et si ça interpelle c'est le
manque de maîtrise aujourd'hui qui en
ressort pour un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle qui suscite qui suscite
des doutes et j'en termine j'en termine
sur ce point peut-être que jean luc
mélenchon se prend un petit peu les
pieds dans le tapis à sa propre
stratégie
vous savez il a lancé sa campagne il ya
quelques quelques mois maintenant en
disant que le temps du bruit et de la
fureur était derrière lui et que à l'âge
qu'il avait l'âge et qui était le sien
il allait mener une campagne apaisée
pour rassembler autour de lui parce que
les françaises dépensent et avait besoin
de confiance et bien le spectacle qui
nous est offert depuis quelques mois
n'est pas celui là
et quand le pays aurait besoin certes de
rupture avec la politique qui est menée
aujourd'hui mais de rupture ordonnée et
bien c'est plus finalement souffler sur
les braises et attiser le chaos et je ne
suis pas sûr que c'est ce dont le pays a
besoin aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya un
besoin d'art quasiment et il n'est pas
retranscrit aujourd'hui en tout cas par
la campagne quand même jean luc
mélenchon j'ai casanova vous mettra
certainement répondre à françois cocq
sur sur la question qui vous est posée
ce qui est nette
c'est que l'homme d'état lorsqu'il
s'exprime ne dit que les choses utiles
et nécessaires
il ne parle pas de tous n'importe
comment
or là on est en face de tout n'importe
si il y à des complots dans l'histoire
il y en a de nombreux l'assassinât du
duc de guise le complot des pauvres sous
jacques premier en angleterre et il y en
a de très nombreux des complots depuis
l'antiquité
si il pense utile de dénoncer un complot
il vient avec des preuves il dénonce ce
complot il dit qui a fait quoi comment
ça c'est un homme d'état qui veut
exprimer la vérité et la faire partager
au peuple et rassembler autour de lui
mais là ce n'est pas du tout les cas il
n'y a aucune forme de preuve
il mélange des choses qui sont un peu
sans rapport il dit que le but est de
monter les gens contre les musulmans
avant l'échéance électorale pour sortir
du chapeau 1 emmanuel macron on a du mal
à comprendre la logique qui présiderait
à un tel choix
non il s'agit là de tout chez les 20 à
25 personnes qui pensent que tout cela
c'est un complot c'est un clin d'oeil
qui leur dit je pense comme vous vous
allez voir que tout le monde va me
tomber dessus
je vais être obligé de dire le contraire
mais vous sauverez que je pense comme
vous c'est une figure de politique et de
communication classique c'est à cela que
nous assistons jean luc mélenchon cet
après midi a dénoncé une manipulation
odieuse en conférence de presse pour
tenter d'éteindre la polémique
est-ce que c'est réussi ou pas et jean
luc mélenchon lors de cette même
conférence de presse a évoqué la vidéo
de youtube heures à dénommer papa cytos
simulant le meurtre d'un électeur et les
filles est à dire un appel au meurtre
sur lui et là la question serait
division médiatique ou sincère
préoccupation françois cocq comment
est-ce que vous interprétez cette prise
de parole cet après midi cette
conférence de presse de jean luc
mélenchon pour tenter d'éteindre
l'incendié ou faire diversion il ya deux
aspects sur le sur le premier jean luc
mélenchon nous a habitués à être maîtres
de raison et a porté très haut avec le
verbe la conviction qui est la sienne
la raison est plus haut en en appelant à
l'esprit humain finalement c'est cette
dimension là et monsieur casanova le
dizet qui est manquante dans la
démonstration qu'il a fait sur le
plateau dimanche le deuxième aspect
c'est qu'à côté de la raison jean luc
mélenchon est l'héritier le porter le
héros d'un courant de pensée qui est
celui du matérialisme qui se base sur
les faits et qu'il ait retranscrit
ensuite dans une bulle dans une pensée
politique et de ce point de vue là jean
luc mélenchon s'est comporté ce dimanche
plus en prophète quand matérialiste
quand il dit tout est écrit tout est
écrit à la suite donc rompt avec
finalement les
deux critères qui sont les critères qui
lui sont attachés jusqu'à maintenant
qu'ils inscrivent sur la scène politique
française et qu'il inscrive dans
l'héritage d'un courant de pensée au
sens au sens large large c'est une
rupture extrêmement importante
quant à sa conférence de presse
aujourd'hui certes le problème est que
un amalgame effet entre la polémique née
de ses propos d'hier
et là la vidéo de youtube heures par pas
si tôt mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que pour le coup jean luc mélenchon
totalement raison d'attirer l'attention
sur le danger que représente une telle
vidéo sur la menace qu'elle comporte
et il serait important que les pouvoirs
publics et le ministre de l'intérieur en
premier lieu parce qu'il est question là
c'est lui qui est le garant du de la
bonne tenue du sculpteur que le ministre
de l'intérieur s'en saisissent saisisse
la justice de l'appel au meurtre qui est
celui qui très clairement et dans cette
vidéo
et de ce point de vue là tout soutien
doit être apporté à l'ensemble de celles
et ceux qui se présente devant les
électeurs et en l'occurrence à jean luc
mélenchon et au mitan de la france a
soumise mais je crois qu'on a affaire à
deux affaires qui sont extrêmement
extrêmement différentes et qui doivent
être traités de la sorte rapidement gym
casanova pour revenir sur cette
conférence de presse cet après midi de
jean luc mélenchon pour tenter
d'éteindre l'incendié et de parler donc
de cette fameuse vidéo
il n'y a pas de rapport entre les deux
il est parfaitement indispensable que
l'état apporte au président d'un groupe
parlementaire menacé publiquement tout
le soutien logistique et matériel
nécessaire et que la justice se
s'emparent de ce sujet et que les
personnes concernées soit entendue et
déférées devant des juridictions autant
que nécessaire et que la loi s'applique
avec la plus grande sévérité
ce sont des choses qui n'ont rien à voir
avec les propos de la veille ce sont
d'ailleurs des choses qui sont
antérieures merci à vous d'avoir répondu
à nos questions j'y casanova je rappelle
que vous êtes consultant en stratégie en
communication merci également à vous à
françois cocq essayiste et ancien
orateurs nationale de la france remises